let's get to monica in los angeles
monica how in the world are we doing
hi dr d thank you for taking my call
today thank you so much for calling it's
it's not even it's still the middle of
the night in los angeles right
uh no it's actually like 8 30 in the
morning right now
all right very cool so hey how can i
help
um so i i guess i
am having some difficulty between
like my mentality i have a long term
boyfriend
and right now we're kind of like in
relationship limbo
as i would call it and i'm really
struggling between like
you said wait you said long-term
boyfriend and in relationship limbo
which one is it
um well right now we're
in relationship limbo but we had been
together for about
uh almost two and a half years okay
um but the the main issue that we've
been having is that he
majority of my friends are guys and
he just never wanted anything to do with
them
and he didn't want me he didn't trust me
hanging out with him
um alone without him and even if i did
take him with me
he just in a sense acted like they
didn't exist
and didn't really associate himself with
them or anything
and it's something that i've been like
continuously bringing up to him because
i
slowly detached myself from my friends
because of it
uh thinking you know he's just
insecure because in his past you know
five-year relationship
his uh ex-girlfriend left him for
another guy
and you know if i can just show him you
know i'm not her
and i'm not there to like leave him um
things will get better and so
so here's the deal they they won't
because that's not something that you
can solve
monica that's not a
you can't fix him on this one
the the the decision you've got before
you is this
you've got a guy that got hurt and
that's fair right he got cheated on he
was with somebody for a long time she
broke his heart
and now he likes you and
you've got a set of friends that are a
bunch of dudes right right wrong or
indifferent
you got some friends that are a bunch of
dudes have you ever dated any of these
guys by the way
no no no no are these just work buddies
college buddies like
where how do you know these dudes
uh mostly from work and then i have a
couple that i met in class
in in college okay i've never dated i've
never flirted with any of them
or anything like that so none of that
for him none of that matters
this is um an alarm system issue for him
right so this is one time
he was sitting at the front of his cave
or at the back of his cave and a tiger
showed up and
mauled him and now every time he
walks by any sort of cat-shaped object
he's taken off running right um
he's been down that road before and
until he does his own healing
and his own work um that alarm system is
going to continue to go off
that's nothing you can do you can't um
you can't constantly be mining your day
and your life
for how he's gonna respond you can be
hospitable and not a jerk
the question you're gonna have to decide
is do you love him
do you want to spend the rest of your
life with him and in this current state
being with him means
that he doesn't want you hanging out
with a bunch of other guys
um or do you like these work friendships
more than you like this guy
that's the basic question because you're
not gonna be able to fix him over here
so what do you choose
monica are you there yeah i'm sorry
no that's okay it's just like i guess a
really tough pill to swallow
yeah it's hard do you love this guy
yeah i really do is he good to you
yes so what is it about these other
guys what is it about hanging out with
other other men
what is it about them that is worth
hurting the guy that you love
oh they just they've been my friends
for like four or five years yeah it just
it sucks because that's basically my
social circle
and it's and it's not that i haven't
tried being friends with girls it's just
all the girls that i've encountered they
have boyfriends and they
they feel like i'm there to like
try to you know do something behind
their backs with their boyfriends or
something like that and it's just
i just feel like i i don't feel like i
have the best of luck
when it comes to like trying to be
friend girls because they always feel
like i have
like an ulterior motive in some way
shape or form
do you approach people with a flirty
energy with a sexy energy is that kind
of your thing no
no i'm literally just friendly
you're just kind i yeah i just asked you
know how's your day
um you know you look kind of sad is
everything okay at home
um is there anything i can do to cheer
you up and that's that's
pretty much it but somehow
i don't know and so i've been with the
same woman for over 20 years
and if i'm out to dinner and
she has a friend and her friend's
husband
pulls up next to my wife and says hey
you look really sad
um how are things going like everything
okay
like there's anything i can do to help
you out i'm gonna knock that dude's
teeth out the back of his head i'm
probably gonna go to jail
and then i'm gonna have to be all weird
here at work at ramsay solutions i'm
gonna have to like go to a board meeting
and explain to them why i got arrested
for punching some strange guy
in a restaurant right so here's the
thing i want to honor your heart here
right i know that i'll trust you that
you have no ultra motives you're a good
human being you're just kind
the world desperately needs more kind
people in the world right
the other side of that is man sometimes
um
when everyone around us is sending us
the same signal
at some point we gotta go to the mirror
right we gotta go to the mirror and say
what am i contributing to my own misery
what am i
contributing to my inability to make
friends here right
and so if folks if if new girlfriend new
girlfriend afternoon girlfriend
has a weird vibe at some point you got
to get somebody that you trust whether
that's a counselor or
a uh mentor or somebody from your church
or somebody just in your friend's circle
and say like man tell me the truth
do i do i just weird people out do
people think i'm hitting on their
boyfriends
and you might have to make some
behavioral changes in your life if you
want to have community right if you want
to have friends
and that brings me back to the central
question that you called about is this
you cannot fix your boyfriend you can't
fix him
he has asked you to
not spend your extracurricular time
whatever time you have between work and
school
with a bunch of other guys he's asked
you for that time
it doesn't sound super unreasonable to
me
in fact that sounds appropriate if y'all
are getting more serious you're getting
more
locked in together you're thinking about
what tomorrow might look like you're
thinking about getting married to this
do you think about having kids with this
guy
at some point you're going to have to
let those other
like college buddy dudes you're going to
let those circles
fade off into the mist man they were fun
they were exciting and now i'm
creating a world i'm co-creating this
new universe with this guy
um or you're gonna have to look in the
eye and say man you won't be a guy
that makes me give up my friends i don't
want that i want to keep hanging out
with my buddies after work
and you're gonna have to wish him well
and i know that's a hard either or
monica but
two and a half years man you know
whether you love him or not you know
they're gonna spend the rest your life
with this dude
and you also know his pain you know his
experiences you know his hurt
and he's drawn a line for you and so i'm
gonna recommend you get with somebody
that you trust
you have a hard conversation and you
stop stringing him along you stop
stringing you along
you stop stringing you long make the
hard call dude make the hard call monica
thank you so much for the call
call me back i want to know how this
thing ends